hello everyone and welcome to an
absolute thriller of a game from the
last round of the 23rd european team
championship it's team france versus
team azerbaijan and on board one we have
ali reza firuja versus shakhtar
mamidarov another former member of the
2800 club and as usual we are continuing
this mini alireza saga will he reach uh
the 2800 rating and will he be the
youngest ever person to ever achieve
this uh
incredible milestone so it's a it's a
brutal game you guys are gonna enjoy it
let's check it out alireza has the white
pieces and he opens with e4 uh we have
e5 by mamedyarov knight to f3 knight to
c6 and bishop to c4 the italian game is
on the board we have bishop to c5 the
joko piano
and now uh well yeah i know you guys are
thinking already as i probably went for
the evans gambit because you know uh he
he needs a win to clinch that 2800
but you know
your surprise is you know just as great
as mine he doesn't he goes for castles
uh and now we have knight to f6 we have
d3 so this is all very standard stuff
the the top of the top of the moves uh
h6 and c3 now uh preparing to strike in
the center at some point also uh you
could start expanding on the queen side
we have d6 and rook to e1 uh castles by
mamadara and now h3 taking away that g4
square from amigarh's pieces we have a5
now stopping white's expansion on the
queen side
and knight b to d2 so many many lines
played in this exact same line nothing
out of the ordinary here bishop to e6
and now not bishop to b5 bishop to b5 is
the you know move that pretty much
everyone plays here uh it is just
captures on e6 this is uh
supposed to be a surprise as there are
very very few games where where this was
played so okay mommy are captured we
have f captures and e6 now black has a
double e pawn but he does get the
semi-open file for his rook which could
be used for
attacking purposes we have knight to b3
uh and now there is a game where bishop
to b6 was played but here mamadara plays
bishop to a7 and it is now already as of
movie 11 that we have a completely new
game which is pretty uh pretty
incredible for a joko piano
now it's pretty much the same because in
the game where bishop the b6 was played
the the idea is the same bishop to e3 we
want to counter black's bishop as it's
just a monster here and our own dark
square bishop isn't really doing all
that much so bishop captures an e3 rook
captures on e3 and now a4 uh pushing
back the knight so we win more space and
we
limit the mobility of alireza's knight
on b3 so knight back to d2 and now uh
mamadara strikes in the center with d5
we have rook to e2 uh getting that uh uh
rook out of the way so d4 does not come
with tempo uh and here mama yara really
has to figure out how to go about this
position and he spent some half an hour
contemplating his next move because you
have to figure it out perfectly and he
does it he plays b5 and now what's the
idea behind this uh well a very nice
expansion uh can ali doesn't just play e
captures on d5 and then pick up the pawn
on e5 and if not why not uh well yeah
already that plays e captures on d5 but
now not e captures on the five major
plays knight captures on d5 if you play
e captures on d5 then yes you can pick
up the pawn on e5 but after knight
captures on the e5 uh you can't really
uh capture or capture this pawn because
if you go for something like knight
captures on e5 now or rather you could
capture it now but first we have a3
if you if you go for this it's a very
tricky line where black gets to play
this a3 move uh puts pressure on the b2
pawn and then well it becomes a weak the
c3 pawn is undermined also and it's uh
it's just a very ugly position to face
even after b captures you could also uh
you know this could also be met with
something like queen to f6 going after
the f2 pawn going after the rook the
knight still attacking c3 so maybe a bit
too much to to allow blacks while it is
after knight captures on d5 just plays
a3 prevents black from playing a3 and
now knight to f4 attacking the rook and
the d3 pawn and it looks like a really
really good position for black rook to
e3 by alireza and now
the question is can you capture the d3
pawn not really if you capture d3 uh
then we play queen f1 now we attack the
knight twice and after knight moves we
play queen captures on b5 and this is
not very good for white this is hanging
this is hanging you know it's not um and
not something you would go for
something you would go for with black so
instead uh you could go for the
repetition with knights the d5 but it's
it's a question whether uh you know this
is in the in the true spirit of uh of uh
chess game end of the competition
because here uh azerbaijan and france
are
well battling it out for for first place
there are a couple of other uh very
strong teams like ukraine but you know
nothing is still known uh so you have to
you have to play so we don't see a
repetition here instead we have queen to
e8 uh of course after this rook to e3 so
not another repetition with something
like knight d5 rook back to e1 knight
back to f4 but queen to e8 by mohammed
yav
and now he wants to bring his queen into
the attack which would be very good also
there will be additional pressure on d3
and he wants the well maybe double up
rooks on the f file and continue this
attack uh so how can alireza go about
this he starts with the g3 it's a very
very interesting move he gives up his h3
pawn but he will get his king to a bit
of a safer square and open up the h file
uh so so he can use it for his pieces
and while you could go back with some
like knight d5 then uh for example rogue
back to e1 as the rookie's attack queen
to g6 uh mamidarov boldly grabs the the
pawn and says all right what do you got
he plays knight captures on h3 check
king the g2 and now knight to g5
uh
getting the knight to do the safety all
it is the captures here we have knight
captures h captures and now queen to g4
putting pressure on g5 and e6 and the
situation on the clock here is some 39
minutes for alireza and 35 minutes for
mamidarov so still quite a few moves
have to be played before reaching move
40 and uh you know being granted
additional time so rook five defending
against the both threats and now comes
knight to f3 and this is a maybe um a
position where
rook to h1 would have been a better idea
the point is that we want to play queen
h3 try and do some damage here but black
would have to be incredibly precise to
survive this something like knight to e7
for example queen h3 and going here and
now even g4 saying that okay if you
deliver this check my king will be
perfectly fine on f7 so you're going to
have to capture here and then i'm going
to play knight to d5 attack your rook
and after the rook moves sound like
knight to f6 and then maybe black can uh
you know
survive this but instead alireza played
knight to f3 uh also knights to e4 is a
possibility but knight to f3 allows
black to really really uh
increase the pressure here and mama yara
played a queen to f7 now the knight
can't really move because we're gonna
capture on f2 uh yeah but even though
the knight could move for example knight
captures on g5 rook captures on f2 with
check and now we could move the king
king to g1 and now what do you play uh
the queen is still hanging we would have
to play queen to f5 and now we just
capture queen captures here and
what do you play now you can't capture
with the pawn to one double because your
rook is hanging you'd have to capture
with the rook then knight captures an e6
attack c7 for example defending and we
get this um sort of an equal-ish
position with equal material but alireza
has two pawn islands mommy daryl has
three pawn island so maybe white would
be slightly better uh but uh there's
also another fine line after knight
captures and g5 not capturing here you
could play queen g6 just attack the
knight the knight cannot move the queen
here would be hanging so here maybe
queen e4 attack the knight and now rook
a to f8 a really really crazy maneuver
knight h3 we have to guard the f2 pawn
and now knight back to e7 and and now
maybe we can play this so this is what
would happen basically uh if uh after
this queen to f7 move uh we go for
knight captures and g5 but alireza goes
for queen to e4 instead attacks the
knight if the knight moves the real king
so how can mama yara survive this he
plays rook to f8 now triples here on the
f file and now well a move like like g4
could be could be troublesome uh if you
capture the knight if the knight is
captured g4 and uh well you you are not
going to keep the piece that's the least
of your concerns so instead we have rook
to h1 finally this rook uh enters the
the attack and now you have to be
careful if the rook moves queen to h7
will be checkmate as the rook and queen
both cover the h7 square
so how do you defend this well there are
a couple of really good ways the the
best one seems to be queen to f6 and
we're going to show it even though it
wasn't played in the game now the point
is after g4 of course we wanted the rook
to move so we have access to the h7
square another weird arrow sorry about
that uh problem is after uh rooked uh
f4 you can't capture on c6 if you
capture on c6 uh then uh we can easily
you know bring this to to a draw just
captures here and after the king moves
we're going to play e4 now and now the
queen no longer defends the knight and
after d captures an e4 rook back to f4
now put
immense pressure on this knight here and
uh you're going to have to start running
away with the king because if you play h
r3 or something like that then g4 and
now black is really breaking through
so uh it's a it's a very interesting uh
position uh
so instead after rook to f4 you would
have to maybe play queen to h7 but uh
this is maybe even worse after king to
f7 the black king now runs away and it's
only the white king who will have to
suffer the attack so queen to f6 after
rook to h1 definitely
uh the way to go but mahmoud plays g6 it
seems like uh it should be working but
it's a weakening the king maybe a little
too much so here are this place queen
captures in c6 we have g4
as expected the king to g1 now uh and
now rook captures on f3 we have rook
captures nf3 queen captures on f3 and
now of course not trading queens all it
is a place queen captures on e6 this
comes with check queen to f7 and here
all it is a trades queen captures an f7
and now what do you capture this with do
you capture with the king or with the
rook uh if you capture with the king
then alireza can bring his rook to the
seventh rank with with check and then
we're gonna pick up the c7 pawn and it's
uh it's a very difficult position for
black to play for example rook d8 we're
going to deliver a check here for
example king to f5 defending the pawn
we're going to play rook c5 go after
this pawn and after rook captures on d3
we're going to play rook capture sun b5
and we're up a pawn we have two pawn
islands so black has three pawn islands
uh white would have
excellent chances here
so instead after queen captures on f7 uh
of course rook captures on f7 was played
but now alerissa goes uh for the for the
double the pawns on the g file he plays
rook to h4 goes after the g for pawn
rook to d7 going after the d3 pawn this
is the only black uh counter play black
has rook capture sun g for rook captures
on d3 rook captures on g6 with checking
f7 and now rook to c6 so again rook to
d2 only counter play black has and now
you could capture on c7 with check right
away but it is a place c4 it's a bit of
a bit of a quicker way to eliminate all
the pawns from the board except the ones
on the king side so here we have rook
captures on b2 rook captures on c7 with
check king e6 now rook the c6 check not
allowing um the king to remain here you
can't go here so you have to move
somewhere king to f5 is played now c
captures on b5 and you can't really go
for the pawn if you capture the pawn
then rook to a6 you're going to lose
this pawn as well you're going to be
down two pawns and then it's going to be
uh well you're going to be miserable
there so instead after c captures on v5
we have rook to b3 the only way to play
this with black so uh majora has to play
unique moves to to survive this end game
uh we have b6 and now of course rook
captures an a3 all it is that pushes b7
now comes rook to b3 defending against
the the promotion and rook to a6 we have
rook captures on b7 and the rook
captures on a4 so this is the absolute
best alireza could have gotten uh from
uh from the end game that that was uh on
the board uh all of the pawns on the
queen side have been eliminated and now
this is the position so can this be one
uh
well let's see what happens so here we
have e4 keeping those pawns at bay uh
it's not going to be easy for y to
activate we have rook to a5 check king
f6
and the king to f1 all it is i will try
to bring his king into the game but rook
to b3 of course mama yara will not allow
this king e2 we have rooked the c3 now
comes rook to a8 and here uh rook to b3
uh we have rooked the f8 with check and
now comes king the e5 momodaro brings
his king deeper into the position and
here alireza plays king to f1 it seems
like uh you know just a normal movie or
maybe even thinking about repeating the
position but maybe something incredibly
dangerous lurks in the position so uh
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find it the only way to save this
position for mamidarov while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are a true
machine when it comes to the end games
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show uh the correct idea for
black is rook to f3 this is the only
move that works uh point being that if
the rooks are traded of the board then
this is a well-known end game that's a
draw for example king e1 we're gonna uh
block that the white king from entering
the game king d4 king d2 king d4 and
we're always going to keep the
opposition and we don't really care what
white does here so
that's uh what would happen if you
captured the rook but it doesn't help if
rookie check we're just going to play
king to d4 if we play king to g2 now
hoping to start advancing our pawn at
some point we're just going to play king
back to d5 and if you start advancing
the pawn well it's a bit a little bit
different with the rook on f3 uh because
just rook f4 attacks the pawn and if
king defends the pawn then just rook
repeats rook f3 check now you either
move the king and lose this pawn or you
you know defend and rook f4 again uh and
there is no way for white to make
progress however after king to f1 mahmud
did not find rook to f3 he played king
to d4 and now incredible as it is the
position is completely winning for
alireza he plays king to g2 and now
there is no more uh
there no more is a way for for the g
pawn to be stopped uh out of out of
nowhere alireza completely outplays
mamidarov as you can see the rook
completely controlling the
the f file the pawn will now be pushed
forward the king cannot help out with
this and there is no way for the black
rook to
uh somehow try and you know do something
about this there is nothing you can do
if you try some tricky moves like e3
trying to you know trade something off
the board we can just capture here and
you can't capture with the king because
then just a rook here and the rook is
lost and of course if rook captures uh
rook to d8 with check and it's not much
better yeah the the king now has to move
you can't go in front of the rook
because again we just trade and after
the king moves uh well king king h3 and
the king is again cut off from the same
game this is of course completely
winning so here mamadar tries rook to b7
but now comes king to h3 we have king to
e5 and here alireza plays g4 the pass
pawn is now being pushed forward and he
was in this position on move 51 that
shakhtar mamidar resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
which means that alireza is now in live
ratings we have to remember over 2800 so
that would make him the youngest player
ever to achieve this incredible
milestone i think he
breaks carlson's record by some six
months which is incredible in itself so
it's not yet official uh because the
ratings get updated every first of the
month so only on first of december will
this become official so if alersa place
more games and loses them somehow
somewhere uh then this will not happen
but i doubt that he will uh he will be
playing uh you know any games uh before
december so a big congratulations to all
it is that this is simply incredible uh
here you can see let me just load this
up uh real quickly
so there you have it uh to make this
official uh there you have it carlson uh
still of course uh in first place with
28.55
alireza with 2803 which means that in
this uh event or rather in this month he
he won 33.8 points which is for someone
who was rated uh 20 27 70 is just
incredible he uh he won all the games um
and only only drew against the shahrich
and grishok the games you you've seen
and uh well that's uh i mean such an
incredible run breaking 2800 like this
uh truly deserving and uh well uh it
seems like you know the uh mamiyarov
could have drawn this game you know a
couple of times but uh it's a team event
so you don't want to draw the game like
maybe you know 15 moves in into the game
and uh then you know you have this
position you know that it's a draw it's
it's you're up upon it's a rock and game
of course it's a draw but alireza still
manages to outplay him
and uh well
there you have it alireza is now a 2800
player as of uh first of december uh and
also i don't know what this means for
the standings because ukraine also uh
ukraine and france have the same amount
of points so i don't know who wins first
place but as soon as i find out i will
inform you guys
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it big congratulations to
alireza who now joins magnus as the two
of them are the only two members of the
2800 club uh i would like to thank micah
kennedy constantinos
rod hill tudor shopper and david kimura
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing uh the coverage uh well not
of this event but of
something else that could be happening
in the chess world uh checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world uh so
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day and i just
remembered uh okay even if you if you
want to try something here for example
rook h7 checking g3 let's say rook g7
we're just gonna play rook to f5 check
that's why uh it doesn't work king e6
king f4 you're gonna win this spawn uh
there's nothing you can do whatever
whatever you you play g5 can be played
now you're gonna win this and it's two
pawns up of course completely winning uh
forgot to mention this so after g4 he
resigned uh thank you all and i will see
you soon have an excellent rest of your
day